welcome back to CBS mornings we are
looking ahead to this Saturday's royal
coronation in London which Prince Harry
will attend without his wife Megan The
Duchess of Sussex she will stay in
California with their two children and
Harry is expected to spend less than 48
hours in the UK
is it an indication that Harry and
Megan's relationship with the other
Royals may be more strained than ever
some people think so Holly Williams is
outside Buckingham Palace with more on
that part of the story Holly good
morning to you
hey there Gail I am all dressed up this
morning because later on today I'll be
attending the Buckingham Palace Garden
Party hosted by members of the royal
family but one person who won't be at
the Garden Party or the coronation is
Megan Duchess of Sussex we took a look
at why she may have decided not to come
The Last Time Prince Harry saw his
family was at the late Queen's funeral
back in September
it seemed that King Charles offered an
olive branch I want also to express my
love for Harry and Megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
and when Harry and his brother William
along with their wives met with members
of the public outside Windsor Castle
there were hopes it signaled a
Reconciliation
but away from the cameras things were
reportedly tense there was definitely
not any great personal warmth between
the two couples I mean when it was over
it was over they went their separate
ways they didn't even go in the same car
together Valentine Lowe is Royal
correspondent for the times of London he
told us it was predictable that Megan
would decide not to attend the
coronation what would you read into that
uh
she thinks I've had enough of this
family no I think you remembered that
that you know it's quite predictable
that might happen it becomes slightly
less of a drama if she doesn't come here
so I think it's just thought let's
lessen the damage lessen the pain we're
not coming we're happy to lie to protect
my brother since the funeral Harry and
Megan have released their Netflix series
they wasn't being thrown to the Wolves I
was being fed to the Wolves I and
Harry's published his book spare
promoting it with tell all interviews
including on 60 Minutes in the book you
call this a full-scale rupture can it be
healed yes the board is very much in
their call there needs to be a
constructive conversation one that can
happen in private that doesn't get late
the palace wants this whole issue to go
away so is that right you say the palace
and yes the palace as an institution
does but also the family you always got
to remember these people you know and we
all have family rights don't we in
family disputes and it's very hard to
conduct what is bitter and painful
family dispute in the public eye
won't be attending but exciting site
here is mounting for the coronation
which
three days away this country hasn't
crowned a new monarch for 70 years and
we'll be covering it live from just
outside Westminster Abbey where they've
been crowning kings and queens since the
Year 1066. back to you guys in New York
Holly you look ready for the garden
party I just said to Tony is that
something in her hair it's a headband
you look fantastic wish I was going to
the garden party thank you so much thank
you thank you I like what the bye-bye I
like what the uh the gentleman in her
piece just said all families have rows
yes all people have you know Squad
family yeah so all these people were
talking I wonder if they've talked to
anybody in the family let them figure
out a way to work I mean all families
are dysfunctional but as someone in the
Paramount documentary says this is a
spectacularly dysfunctional family so
it's it's actually that word yeah they
did use that word